book book recommendation for when josh
josh was josh was
alive we're happy for him as you all
know i'm divorced my
ex-wife her new husband that lying dirt
bag
who i love and we're all very happy is
alive joshua
he's just you know it's a little clumsy
boy slipped accidentally because rescue
teams couldn't find him we just assumed
that he was uh
that would just he just died it looked
like you know for a while it was an open
open open shut case apparently there
were so many
sideways trees along the grand canyon
that he just hit them he's a little
bruised up but
why does my stomach hurt so he has
slight amnesia but doctors are working
with him they
are expecting a full recovery oh why is
that like that crazy misunderstanding i
know deborah doesn't mean any
harm by it but she did press charges i
think i basically
attempted murderer but it's just a total
misunderstanding you know i don't take
it personally
i'm gonna be my own lawyer but i do need
some training so for lawyer class i
started selling furniture
stop paying my electric bill i'm going
to the university of phoenix online
it's a great it's a great place to go to
school debra i love
debra so she charged me with attempted
murder and she's testifying against me
so be it part of the crazy course of
life we're going to beat this though and
i have um
a lot of books to wreck recommend
if i just don't move i can do a book
recommend
wrong alibi there's a as a book
they said i was the wrong alibi i'm
gonna go to jail for a long time aren't
i
you